on capitol hill it's in a state of alert
due to new threats of violence
extra security has been added and today
house lawmakers chose
not to meet in person why as a
precaution because today march 4th
is an important date for pro-trump
extremists because it was once america's
actual inauguration day some believe
that the former president will retake
office later today this week the fbi
warned january's violent attack which
killed one police officer and
injured dozens more was unlikely to be
an isolated incident
chris van cleave is along the security
perimeter outside the capitol for us
this morning chris good morning to you
what's it like where you are well good
morning security is once again
ramping up outside the capitol in fact
staff have been encouraged to work from
home
if they can and the capitol police have
moved to an all hands on deck
footing for at least the next few days
the nation's capital on high alert this
morning
after a federal intelligence bulletin
warned a group of militia violent
extremists discussed plans to take
control of the u.s capitol
and remove democratic lawmakers on or
about march
4. we do have some concerning
intelligence
that intelligence is law enforcement
sensitive
we've taken immediate steps to let
the national guard as well as our
workforce know
what to expect acting capital police
chief yogananda pittman briefed
lawmakers yesterday
we know that the threats are through the
roof facebook confirms it is monitoring
efforts to attempt or coordinate actions
tied to a q anon conspiracy theory
that former president trump will rise to
power today
these latest threats come as confusion
continues over the timeline of the
january sixth attack
major general william walker the
commander of the d.c national guard told
senators
he received a frantic call at 1 49 p.m
that day from then capitol police chief
stephen sundt
chief's son his voice cracking with
emotion
indicated that there was a dire
emergency
at the capitol and he requested the
immediate assistance
of as many available national guardsmen
that i could muster
but he said it took more than three
hours to get the defense department to
approve sending troops to the capitol
seconds mattered minutes mattered walker
blamed the unprecedented and slow
response
on the pentagon the army senior leaders
did not think that
it looked good it would be a good optic
they further stated
that it could for it could incite the
the crowd
he was asked if that same consideration
had been made last summer when the guard
was also called to respond to black
lives matter protests
it was never discussed the week of june
it was never discussed july 4th
when we were supporting the city it was
never discussed august
28th when we supported the city
this intelligence confusion appears to
be continuing past the sixth
earlier this week the house
sergeant-at-arms sent an email saying it
appeared the threats
aimed at today were on the decline less
than 24 hours later
new alerts saying those threats are back
anthony chris thank you